[Aplausos]
[Música]
estoy seguro de que si os pregunto qué
es la otan la mayoría de vosotros
responderé que es una alianza militar
entre diferentes países que se creó para
hacer frente a la antigua Unión
soviética y efectivamente la otan la
organización del tratado del Atlántico
Norte ya cuenta con 31 países aliados y
32 con Suecia es decir hablamos con
mucha diferencia de la mayor Alianza
militar de todo el mundo y desde luego
creo que todos conocemos el enorme poder
militar de muchos de los ejércitos de
los países que la integran sin ir más
lejos ahí tenemos al todopoderoso
ejército estadounidense Pero y si os
dijera que en la otan hay un país que no
tiene un ejército Pues sí pero os
preguntaréis Cómo puede haber un país
sin ejército en una alianza militar como
es la otan pues efectivamente Este es el
caso de nuestro protagonista de hoy
Islandia en efecto esta esta lejana Isla
entre Europa y América con apenas
370,000 habitantes y que subsiste
principalmente gracias a la fundición de
aluminio la pesca y el turismo es el
único país de la otan que no tiene
ejército de hecho muchos piensan que
esta es la principal razón de que
Islandia sea el país más Pacífico del
mundo un puesto que lleva ostentando más
de una década pero a pesar de ello no
nos engañemos Islandia no es el primer
país ni será el último en no tener un
ejército en el mundo hay más de 30
países que no tienen fuerzas armadas
hablamos de lugares como andorra Mónaco
o incluso Panamá y si os fijáis tienen
una particularidad común y es que todos
ellos son países con poca población sin
embargo lo lógico sería pensar que si un
país está dentro de una alianza militar
es porque tiene un ejército propio y
puede aportar con él no os parece pues
queréis saber lo más sorprendente de
todo durante mucho tiempo Islandia fue
un miembro muy importante de la otan es
decir a pesar de que no ha tenido
ejército Islandia cuenta con otro activo
tremendamente valioso para la otan su
posición geográfica de hecho ya durante
la Guerra Fría se convirtió en un uno de
los territorios más codiciados por las
grandes superpotencias La pregunta es
por qué Qué tiene de importante su
localización en el mapa mundial Cómo ha
logrado Islandia sacar provecho de su
ubicación Qué papel juega esta isla en
un Ártico cada vez más militarizado por
Rusia pues hoy vamos a responder a esta
y más preguntas así que sin más
preámbulo arranquemos
[Música]
el poder de la
geografía os hago una pregunta Qué es lo
primero que si os viene a la cabeza si
os pregunto por Islandia quizás los
vikingos quizás volcanes cuyas cenizas
pueden llegar a paralizar Europa Pues sí
cualquiera de estas dos cosas son muy
características de esta isla pero al
margen de eso hablamos de un país que
normalmente ha pasado bastante
desapercibido a lo largo de la historia
moderna Al fin y al cabo históricamente
fue una lejana isla del reino de
Dinamarca de solada por la pobreza las
hambrunas las epidemias e incluso por
alguna que otra erupción volcánica sin
sin embargo el destino de este lugar
empezaría a cambiar a mitad del siglo
pasado cuando Reino Unido primero y
luego Estados Unidos ocuparon la isla
entre 1940 y 1944 para hacer frente a la
Alemania nazi en el norte del Océano
Atlántico para los islandeses fue
Inevitable Ya que en 1869 abolieron su
propio ejército El caso es que con el
tiempo y sobre todo en el siglo XX
Islandia se convirtió en un punto
estratégico y eso era algo que Estados
Unidos tenía muy claro por este motivo
El Tío Sam pronto comenzó a negociar con
Islandia su entrada a la
otan conseguida su independencia en
1944 Islandia fue rápidamente consciente
de su privilegiada posición
geoestratégica como vigilante del Norte
del Atlántico y aparte de eso en ravik
también tenía muy presente la ocupación
extranjera de la isla y su indefensión
Así que el movimiento era claro
convertirse junto a otros países
europeos Estados Unidos y Canadá en
miembro fundador de la otan que pasaría
a ser uno de los Pilares fundamentales
de su defensa sin embargo tras el
comienzo de la guerra de Corea el miedo
en la isla ser atacada por la unión
soviética se disparó Islandia necesitaba
efectivos militares en la isla
urgentemente por eso en 1951 cerró un
acuerdo de defensa con Estados Unidos un
acuerdo que sigue vigente hasta nuestros
días y que es el otro Pilar fundamental
de la seguridad islandesa desde ese
momento y hasta 2006 en Islandia se
desplegó la llamada fuerza de defensa de
Islandia una fuerza que contaba con 1350
militares norteamericanos y otros 100
civiles del departamento de defensa en
la base aeronaval de keflavik Islandia
ya era
segura el país de los volcanes
impronunciables consiguió lo que buscaba
explotar su posición geográfica para
conseguir protección pero no se quedó
solamente ahí y si os dijera que los
gobiernos de Islandia en esta época
fueron algo retorcidos y si os dijera
que el chantaje fue un método más que
habitual para el gobierno
islandés por ejemplo entre los años 50 y
70 Islandia se enfrentó al Reino Unido
por las zonas pesqueras en lo que se
conoció como guerras del bacalao
Islandia iba ampliando progresivamente
sus zonas sin negociar con Reino Unido y
esto derivaba en fuertes tensiones bien
pues en todo este embrollo Estados
Unidos nunca se atrevió a posicionarse
del lado británico la posición
geopolítica de Islandia era demasiado
importante para vigilar de cerca a una
Unión soviética muy activa en la región
ya sabéis por el interés te quiero
Andrés así como veis en este mapa fue
como Islandia consiguió ampliar de
manera salvaje Su zona económica
exclusiva y sus zonas de pesca hasta las
200 millas náuticas Y sí ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando pero si ese límite es
el que le corresponde a todos los
estados con Costa Pues sí no os falta
razón sin embargo lo curioso de esta
historia es lo rápido que consiguieron
ampliar Su zona económica exclusiva
prácticamente por
10 no obstante pronto se les iba a
acabar el choyo Unión soviética cayó y
la Guerra Fría terminó la amenaza
comunista desapareció de repente y con
ella la urgencia estadounidense de tener
una base en Islandia también se esfumó
por eso desde entonces Estados Unidos
comenzó a retirar sus tropas de la isla
de tal forma que en 2006 ya no quedaba
ninguna bota estadounidense en suelo
islandés la fuerza de defensa de
Islandia pasó a la historia y la base de
que flavi fue cedida al gobierno de La
Isla que la convirtió en el principal
Aeropuerto Internacional del país el
acuerdo de defensa con Estados Unidos de
1951 continúa en vigor y así sigue
estando hoy pero ya no hay efectivos
militares en la isla sin embargo eso no
quita a que la marcha del ejército
americano dejase un enorme vacío de
seguridad al menos psicológicamente
hablando con una sensación de que el
país insular había perdido toda la
relevancia geoestratégica que tanto supo
aprovechar durante décadas y
precisamente por esto Islandia comenzó a
actuar reikiavik empezó a hacerse cargo
de su seguridad pero sin un ejercicio
propio cómo diantres lo haría Pues bien
[Música]
atentos gélidas
tensiones Por cierto es que muy pocas
veces encontramos territorios que han
tardado más de 60 años en legislar sobre
seguridad en sus territorios como ha
hecho Islandia a fin de cuentas la
seguridad es una de las prioridades para
cualquier país que quiera sobrevivir
ante las adversidades del mundo no
obstante la realidad es que hay Islandia
no le hizo falta hacerlo hasta que las
tropas estadounidenses se marcharon de
su país eso sí una vez que Islandia se
dio cuenta de su nueva realidad no tardó
en tomar cartas en el asunto a partir de
entonces firmó acuerdos de cooperación
con otros socios de la otan creó su
agencia de defensa y aprobó su ley de
defensa en el año 2008 y Asimismo en
2016 desarrolló su política de seguridad
nacional vamos que quietos no se
quedaron Por esa razón hoy Islandia
cuenta con una Guardia costera que
aunque existe desde 2018 nunca ha sido
tan grande como es ahora contando con
nada menos que 200 efectivos entre sus
filas cuatro buques y tres helicópteros
medios Además desde la salida de Estados
Unidos se han reforzado las
instituciones policiales del país y por
si fuera poco Islandia cuenta con un
cuerpo paramilitar la unidad de
respuesta a crisis que funciona como una
pequeña fuerza para operaciones de
mantenimiento de paz internacionales
pero ojo porque aún hay más Islandia
también cuenta con dos activos cruciales
para la otan aquí hablamos de su sistema
de defensa aérea que opera cuatro
complejos radares que sirven como
sistemas de alerta temprana para los
aliados de La otan y por otra parte es
su segundo gran activo es el territorio
y su clima que de hecho son
excepcionales para hacer ejercicios
militares especialmente duros conocidos
Como los Northern viking no obstante un
momento aquí hay que ser honestos las
capacidades defensivas de Islandia
siguen siendo más bien escasas sobre
todo si quiere hacer frente a retos de
seguridad importantes y esto no es moco
de pavo veréis su reducida capacidad
militar es Realmente preocupante si
echamos un vistazo a lo que está
sucediendo en uno de los puntos más
próximos a Islandia y que mayor
importancia estratégica lleva ganando
estas dos últimas décadas por supuesto
aquí nos referimos al
[Música]
Ártico el Ártico del cual ya os hemos
hablado anteriormente en visual politic
ha ido ganando especial relevancia en
los últimos años por una razón muy
concreta el deshielo amigos el mayor
derretimiento estival de masas de hielo
está permitiendo que nuevas rutas
comerciales aparezcan y se consoliden al
tiempo también que se está abriendo la
posibilidad de poder explorar los vastos
recursos que se dice que alberga esta
región hablamos de hasta un 30% de todas
las reservas mundiales de gas natural y
un 13 por de las de petróleo es por ello
que el Ártico ha ido experimentando una
creciente militarización de parte de un
actor en especial de Rusia y es que
Rusia tiene grandes intereses en la
región ártica Al fin y al cabo el 80% de
su gas natural y casi el 20% de su
petróleo lo produce precisamente allí y
aún más el Ártico también acoge a la
mayor flota naval de Rusia la flota del
Norte al igual que a su mayor salida a
mar abierto por eso no es de extrañar
que Rusia se haya esforzado en
militarizar el Ártico como ningún otro
país triplicando el número de bases que
hoy por hoy tiene la otan en la región
algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en
este
[Música]
canal pero como os podéis imaginar Rusia
no es la única interesada en esta zona
es más china que no es una nación ártica
Como por ejemplo son Suecia Noruega o la
propia Islandia tiene fuertes intereses
en la región pequín cuenta ya con bases
civiles que pueden servir para sus
servicios de inteligencia justo en estos
tres países no obstante el interés del
gigante asiático en esta zona no está
tanto en el terreno militar sino sobre
todo en el potencial comercial que
[Música]
tiene Es que veréis su principal
ambición en la región es potenciar la
ruta marítima del Norte con ello puede
reducir el tiempo y el coste de su
transporte y también por su propia
seguridad con esta ruta china puede
además asegurarse que los cargamentos
que tiene que recibir en sus puertos no
se ven interrumpidos ni en el estrecho
de Málaga ni en el océano Índico donde
Por cierto tien multitud de contingentes
como la propia India y por eso china ha
estado apoyando a Rusia a pesar de las
sanciones precisamente para hacer que
esta ruta se convierta en una vía
realmente estable y claro en semejante
bereng genal no podía faltar por
supuesto Estados Unidos es cierto que el
interés del Tío Sam por el Ártico ha
sido hasta hace poco pues bastante
reducido no obstante con la llegada de
trampa a la presidencia el tema comenzó
a ganar relevancia por ejemplo en 2018
se estableció la segunda flota de
Estados Unidos y en 2020 la potencia
norteamericana llevó a cabo más de 20
ejercicios militares en el Ártico y por
Si eso fuera poco lo cierto Es que en
los últimos tiempos nos hemos encontrado
noticias como la siguiente Islandia
autoriza la visita de submarinos
nucleares estadounidenses esta noticia
de hecho es más reveladora de lo que
parece uno podría que el papel de
Islandia en las disputas de las grandes
potencias en el Ártico no sería
demasiado relevante sin embargo la
realidad es que el papel de esta isla
escasamente habitada y sin ejército es
crucial en todo este puzle estratégico o
dicho de otra forma que Islandia ha
recobrado su importancia geopolítica
ahora bien Por qué justo ahora pues bien
Vamos a
verlo Islandia guardián de La
Brecha Todos hemos estado viendo este
último año y medio como Rusia ha
concentrado sus mayores esfuerzos en
invadir Ucrania hay quien podría pensar
que incluso ha dejado de lado otros
objetivos geopolíticos y Puede que sea
así pero desde luego no es el caso del
Ártico la región gélida del Norte sigue
siendo absolutamente prioritaria para
Putin y por eso sigue fuertemente
militarizada a pesar de todo Claro que
Cualquiera podría pensar que perdiendo
tantísimos recursos en Ucrania en Moscú
no iban a estar pensando en el Ártico
verdad pues nada más lejos de la
realidad esta zona Apenas ha visto
reducidas las capacidades militares
rusas por mar y aire y tan solo un poco
en cuanto a las terrestres de hecho esto
es lo que hace a los países de la otan y
sus aliados estar muy alerta y dado que
la presencia rusa en la región es algo
que difícilmente puede ignorarse
plantarle cara a Moscú de manera directa
no es algo que Islandia se haya
planteado muchas
veces de hecho sus relaciones han sido
incluso positivas por ejemplo en 2013 se
comprometieron a cooperar más
estrechamente en la protección y la
investigación del Ártico además han
llegado a acuerdos en cuanto a pesca
energía y turismo Aunque eso sí todo
esto no les ha hecho olvidar sus
compromisos internacionales por ejemplo
en 2014 Islandia no dudó en condenar los
abusos de Rusia cuando invadieron y se
anexionaron crimea uniéndose también a
las sanciones occidentales a pesar de
que su propia industria pesquera iba a
salir perjudicada a raíz de eso Por
cierto empezaron a ser habituales
noticias como estas bombarderos rusos
avistados en el espacio aéreo islandés
Islandia denuncia que los bombarderos
rusos suponen un peligro para los
aviones civiles y como ya hizo en 2014
cuando Rusia invadió de nuevo Ucrania a
principios de 2022 Islandia volvió a
condenarlo y a sancionarlo es más a
pesar de no tener un ejército propio ni
poder permitirse el lujo de enviar
soldados al frente Islandia ha apoyado a
Ucrania de otras maneras ha donado tres
hospitales de campaña les ha comprado 10
camiones de transporte petrolero y ha
acogido a 3,000 refugiados entre otras
cosas ahora bien todo esto no nos dice
mucho de la renovada importancia
geopolítica que os hemos dicho que ha
cobrado Islandia Y entonces de qué va
eso exactamente pues nada más y nada
menos que de su posición central en un
espacio muy concreto la llamada brecha
huk por las iniciales en inglés de
Groenlandia Islandia y Reino
[Música]
Unido La Brecha hyuk se refiere al
espacio que separa al mar de Noruega del
Océano Atlántico Norte y que va desde gr
hasta el Reino Unido pasando por
Islandia esta región tuvo especial
relevancia en la Guerra Fría ya que se
convirtió en un punto de bloqueo que
separaba el espacio de actuación de la
flota del Norte soviética del espacio
Atlántico de la otan es decir que
funcionaba como una especie de Barrera
contra el ejército rojo por esa razón
huk se convirtió en uno de los espacios
más vigilados de todo el mundo
desempeñando Islandia un papel
especialmente importante Ya que gozaba
de una visión casi periférica y de un
amplio control de toda la
región El caso es que hoy querida
comunidad de viso poli Islandia ha
recobrado su relevante papel en un
momento en el que Rusia se muestra
claramente hostil otra vez con patrullas
de submarinos nucleares y convencionales
no solo en la región del Ártico sino
también en La Brecha hiuk la potencial
vuelta a una situación similar a la de
la guerra fría con submarinos
desplegados alrededor de Islandia y con
vuelos de bombarderos estratégicos ahora
de nuevo amenazantes ha proporcionado a
Islandia una excelente ocasión para
concitar nuevamente el interés militar
de Estados Unidos y de la otan ya lo
veis Islandia es la mejor prueba de que
no se necesita un ejército propio para
tener influencia estar seguro y
prosperar es más Puede que sea uno de
los mejores ejemplos de cómo jugando
bien incluso con las peores cartas se
pueden hacer Milagros Islandia ha vuelto
al tablero geopolítico alimentado por un
nuevo conflicto entre occidente y Rusia
y puede que ahora con un Ártico
fuertemente militarizado por Putin su
papel sea incluso más fundamental para
vigilar la brecha huk que incluso
durante la Guerra Fría pero llegamos a
este punto la pregunta ahora es para ti
estamos ante el inicio de otro largo
periodo de relevancia estratégica
islandesa volverá Islandia a jugar de
forma interesada con sus socios Como
hizo durante la Guerra Fría pedirán una
mayor presencia militar extranjera
frente a una Rusia cada vez más presente
en el Ártico podéis dejarnos vuestras
respuestas abajo en los comentarios como
siempre si os ha gustado este vídeo no
olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros a nuestro canal y por
supuesto dle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras novedades
que estén por llegar una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
[Música]
próxima